from a small village on Mexico's Pacific
Coast fishing boats with powerful
engines speed through estuaries leading
to the ocean
it's early evening but they moved before
dark
on board are members of the Sinaloa drug
cartel one of the most powerful in
Mexico
they're heading to a rendezvous point to
pick up a shipment the cartel says has
been smuggled here from China
on an islet in water too shallow for
Mexico's Security Forces to use their
vessels a man helps load plastic Jerry
cans filled with chemicals known as
precursors
they are the crucial ingredients that
make the opioid drug Fentanyl
this is the first part of a process that
makes the cartel millions of dollars
but fuels an opioid epidemic that's
killing thousands of drug users in the
United States they move quickly Mexican
Marines are always near and drones are a
constant threat
they head to shore
the chemicals are loaded into a car to
be whisked away to a safe house
directions are given to us to join the
gang later that night
the back streets of culiacan the Sinaloa
cartel's headquarters are controlled by
Cartel gunmen
we'll watch constantly as we drive to
the Stash House
the precursors are already here
this is one of the cartel's most senior
players he's in charge of Distributing
the precursors to the fentanyl making
labs
this one Consignment he told me can make
half a ton of the drug
they do this every week
[Music]
it's a huge business
foreign
[Music]
the fentanyl labs are spread across the
state of Sinaloa in towns Villages and
the countryside
we're guided up a remote Hillside
hidden beneath trees and tarpaulin
sheets is a lab where the synthetic
opioid drug is made
it's highly toxic even breathing in the
fumes here is lethal
the U.S drug enforcement agency says
pure fentanyl is so dangerous even a
microscopic dose can be lethal this gang
estimates they make about 50 kilos of
fentanyl a week
it's incredibly dangerous and toxic
stuff
give you some perspective 50 kilos would
kill everyone in London pretty amazing
right except in fact 50 kilos would kill
everyone in London and everyone in Los
Angeles it's incredible to think people
even put this into their bodies for this
big business and they're making a lot of
money
it's going to take a few hours to make
pure fentanyl the two gang members who
create the drug leave their guns on a
tree branch as they work through three
processes
essentially they're adding the Chinese
precursors acid and a variety of other
chemicals they won't reveal to us to
make a porridge-like mash that is then
re-diluted and mixed again
they have no qualms about making this
lethal cocktail
America's
people are dying in America
because of fentanyl do you care about
that
yeah
rock and roll
machines
each part of the process concludes with
a centrifuge removing the water as they
get nearer to the end
the most important people in this whole
process are of course
the men who make the Phantom they call
themselves the cooks and in fact they
they actually pay others to teach them
how to do it
very much like a professional chef they
don't do it just by time
they do it by how it looks what it feels
like if you like and that's how they
know when it's it's each process and
there's three processes that's when they
know that it's done of course at the end
of the third process it's pure fencing
there is a constant mixing stirring and
drying of the product in and out of
sheets and bags before they're finally
happy and indicate they are done they
never take off their gloves respirators
or aprons
the pure fentanyl is emptied into a bowl
they break it into pieces
and move it into the sun to start drying
at another location the now dry fencing
is ground into powder in a smoothie
maker
the drug is carefully weighed to a
single kilo and loaded into a plastic
bag and then completely wrapped in thick
tape
this Consignment will join another batch
of kilo bags and is destined for the
United States
it's placed in a secret lot compartment
the cartel was installed in a pickup
the journey North now begins its
destination Tijuana on the United States
border
once here the drug is swapped into a car
with American number plates and joins
the traffic that constantly crosses
between the two countries the cartel
except some Consignments will be
intercepted but not every car can be
searched
dealers in the United States will start
cutting the fentanyl one kilo can
quickly become 10 kilos and the profits
multiply
if the demand is there this deadly trade
seems Unstoppable
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Mexico